Elon Musk and Joe Rogan reuniting for
another wild podcast the world's richest
man unleashing on a bunch of topics
including Free Speech must dropping a
bomb Shaw Revelation about the social
media platform he owns X previously
known as Twitter the degree to which
Twitter was simply um an arm of the
government was not well understood by
the public a state publication is the
way to think of old Twitter it's a state
publication Republicans were suppressed
at 10 times the rate of Democrats and Mr
musk wasn't done the billionaire
revealing the real reason why he bought
Twitter in the first place I was worried
about that that it was having a
corrosive effect on civilization if
you've walked around downtown San
Francisco right near the xfk Twitter
headquarters it's a zombie apocalypse
which is essentially a mind virus to the
rest of both um and the outcome of that
mind virus is very clear if you walk
around the streets of downtown San
Francisco it is the end of
civilization Greg
I admire him a lot he paid $44 billion
he's amazing uh that by the way that
interview was incredible there is about
15 minutes of it that is horrible when
musk and Rogan eat an anchovy and uh
pineapple pizza and they're oh they're
over the microphone it is the most
disgusting thing but this is so good
just skip over that why would the
world's richest man who could do
anything do this at a great cost to him
it's to save civilization he realized
that from outside looking at Twitter
that it was a silencing mechanism that
was removing dissent for just these
pernicious beliefs of people that
basically live in five square miles
right and they're projecting these crazy
beliefs that have destroyed San
Francisco ultimately around the United
States to create like an open air
apocalypse and you know he's doing it
and he's and he's doing an important
thing because look at the people that
he's scaring you're seeing you're seeing
extinctionist which he talks about
people who believe that your thoughts
are just humans in general need to be
controlled and ultimately silenced if
you were if you're against musk you're
essentially the villain in one of the
greatest movies being being made right
now Dana you have thoughts on this well
I'm furious if anybody who missed a
Jasper or Percy picture because of
censorship or an insult that I tweeted
about Greg because they were really
really good and I could go back in the
archives and see if I can find those for
you no obviously this is a big problem
and I think that it's continued and I
wouldn't be surprised if this is
happening now on Tik Tok I mean if you
look talk about the Mind virus look at
what's happening in terms of
anti-Semitism and the guy who used to
run Tinder said that the more that you
post Pro Palestinian content you get
more views on Tik toks which means that
what do you do you create more of those
same things so that you can get more of
that so it's a self-fulfilling cycle how
about grinder Jesse I I'm just saying he
used to work at Tinder I'm assuming I
don't know anything I don't even know
what that is but anyway anyway I had
another good point to make and that is
this I have always utilized since the
beginning of Twitter utilized it for
work I find it impossible to use now I
find it hard to find breaking news on it
I can't no I don't know what's going on
with it every day there's something
different I you have to go from the for
you to the following to the not that's
confusing it's very confusing and you
you
cannot no you go with the following no
for you so much more fun do you know
what I get on for you it's all dog
videos but I actually need to know
what's going on in the war and it's very
frustrated I hope it gets fixed all
right Kelly what are your thoughts on
this look I'm so happy that Elon Musk
spent $44 billion to do this because a
lot of conservatives really center right
people in this country already knew they
were being censored and shadowbanned and
silenced and canceled but he's put real
figures around it and we have the
evidence now the only people trying to
conceal those facts from us are those
who were perpetrating those facts and
NPR had done a study that in the leadup
to the 2020 election basically
like X percentage of tweets were coming
from a very small percentage of people
like almost all tweets were coming from
very small it's just people talking to
each other and high-fiving each other
but the media used Twitter as an
assignment editor they literally think
it's real and they love to see how many
likes they get and retweets I mean every
I've been very public about I think
Twitter helped um add to the destruction
of my marriage I think it's corrosive to
the body politic and it's distorted
um for people who live online we have a
lot of people in this country now who
live basically online it's where they
get their food their information their
schooling their work their sex their
friendships um get some fresh air live
offline but I'm so happy that M did this
and you're right Greg the pieces of the
interview that I read and I didn't
listen to it like you did are brilliant
I just have to say there's um Elon Musk
tells Joe Rogan the reason he would beat
Mark Zuckerberg in a fight and Elon mus
says Zuck pulled out he used the pull
out out method rugan so he pulled out he
pulled out of the fight M said yeah I
said listen at the end of the day I'd
like to fight you but I don't know a guy
musk's got like 11 kids so I didn't know
he was a fan of the pull out M I didn't
know where you were going with that
there it is prime time give give take us
home here how do you round this out so I
made such a brilliant point yesterday
it's worth repeating I did a deep dive
into the Democratic profile of the
Twitter employees only 50% White
mostly in their 20s all making six
figures 90% vote Democrat all nerdy
computer science Majors all single
mostly living in apartments in San
Francisco so that's one of the Mind
virus Democrats uh mind viruses it joins
forces with the FBI now we did an FBI
Deep dive into their demographics
control freaks Trump derangement
syndrome fouchy lovers who see
everything as a threat to National
Security so this mine virus comingled
with this mine virus created a super
virus I call it a SC up because it
happened at the same time of the
pandemic and the election so everybody
got rich and then Joe Biden got elected
and then we're left picking up the
pieces but I want to know what he was
wearing Elon Musk and I think I figured
it out it's a velvet blazer with a
two-tone underneath see how he's got the
collar and the cuffs and I see that as a
button-down shirt with a orange silk
Blazer but there's something else going
on
if you see that thing coming down from
the collar it's like an extra layer of
skin I don't know what that
is Elon tell us what you're wearing cuz
I got to find out minute L what is that
velvet the fastest is up next hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else